good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday i hope
everyone's having a great tuesday
um i know i am because i'm just like
i've been up for 1 000 hours uh 10 000
[Music]
sometimes i like to see how long you'll
go talking before i can get over it you
know what sometimes i feel you like
staring at me like just like waiting for
mike to say hey
hey guys
i'm here too because just in case the
youtube video isn't processed and you're
listening on a podcast you wouldn't know
that i'm also here i want to apologize
for yesterday's it's not even our fault
like i don't even know who i'm
apologizing for like i'm just such a
woman like always apologizing because
it's youtube's fault youtube took like
almost 24 hours to process our video
from yesterday and it wasn't up until
this morning which is really annoying i
mean the podcast was up at noon and most
people listen as a podcast but still
like the youtube community deserved
better and i'm really sorry yeah we're
again
not our fault but it's there now so if
you want to go watch go watch because it
was a really fun episode we caught up on
so much so if you like sometimes you
need to watch that catch-up episode in
order for all of us to move forward so i
just i feel like you guys starting on
today's episode like you don't know what
i did this weekend right gotta go watch
we caught up on personal we caught up on
love island we did the blind after the
alter recap it's like a big chunky
delicious episode and we both look like
so cute yesterday like i was like living
and i was like no one can see i'm so
upset yeah but also that's why it took
so long to process because it was an
hour and a half long episode which
actually might have been our longest
episode without a guest ever and if ben
hadn't walked in which he'll also say um
we probably would have gone for another
20 minutes yeah yeah exactly so check
that out if you haven't yet but we're
here today on this beautiful tuesday and
it's a really special day
because do to do is here if the video
doesn't process when you're listening as
a podcast you wouldn't know but he's
here and he's sitting with his auntie
because we haven't been together on the
show in in quite a long time and it just
feels so right and i feel so prepared
and like complete would you say complete
and just ready to do the job that i need
to do knowing that i have do
and also if you're
somehow not gonna end up watching this
like i look super cute because i've been
up for literally three hours i had the
longest morning ever because i filmed to
get ready with me for the patreon
because like it was it last month that
you did it i think it was two months
yeah two months ago jackie did like how
i get ready for the choice and everyone
seemed to like it and i actually really
enjoyed it because we couldn't be more
different in our styles of hair and
makeup and also just like our morning
routine which is shocking just because
we're so similar in so many other ways
i'm so excited to watch yours and see
how you do things like you do your
makeup before your hair of course that's
just crazy to me like it's so backwards
i don't think so but i look forward to
seeing you do yours maybe i'll be
changed but i don't think so my my hair
is just like a last-minute you know
last-ditch effort interesting my hair
requires more
upper arm strength so like i have to get
it out of the way oh well once a week my
hair or twice a week probably is when i
do my hair like from scratch but then
the other days it's like pretty much the
same as yesterday just needs a little
bit of touch-ups so you'll see like i
sleep like such an animal that i could
have a full blowout on monday night and
i wake up tuesday morning it's like the
blowout never exists really which is so
annoying
that like i pretty much do my hair in
full every day damn but you have
naturally beautiful hair not anymore i
don't believe you no look you'll see in
the video like i wake up and i did my
hair yesterday morning my hair yesterday
looked so cute and you'll see this
morning when i wake up it's like frizzy
mcgee okay it's frizzle but you're
showing us how to get this look at this
hair yes so i do my hair my makeup
getting ready and it's just like it was
fun i mean i got up so early i over
compensated like i didn't know how long
i would need to film the vlog so i
actually already started editing it so
it'll be up really soon i'm so excited
to watch
truly i love a vlog moment i love when
my sisters vlog like even when snitch
does her vlogs like how fun i know well
snitch happens to have like a super
interesting life yeah i feel like i'm
like boring
no
well when i
no yeah like snitch is just fabulous no
the thing about snitch is that we don't
know what she does so when we're
watching a vlog it's like oh that's what
you did but i know every time you
pee like yeah so when i'm watching the
vlog i'm like oh yeah and here's the
summation of everything that claudia
does but i don't know how you get ready
for the toast so i am looking forward to
that yeah so it'll be up soon i'm very
excited i hope you guys enjoy it and we
have a great show for you guys today the
bachelorette ended last night and even
though jackie and i have not been
watching this season we're still going
to give our unsolicited opinions but if
you're looking for some solicited
opinions the snatchler watch the three
hour finale the chutzpah is unparalleled
the snatchler
watched
so if you're looking for like a really
detailed recap about the whole season
specifically the finale check out the
snatcher um she's recapping it all and
they're still going to go into bachelor
in paradise which we have some bachelor
in paradise news yeah um
and we have your toasters because
remember we recently made a shift a
calendar shift that kind of like i don't
know change the trajectory of our whole
brand you think so i think your toasters
i keep forgetting i just feel like it
changed and it was always meant to be
this way because there is not a single
utterance of complaint yeah and there's
also no tv that we watch on mondays love
island's not on that and we don't watch
a bachelor so tuesdays were always kind
of lackluster but now they're full of
goodness and tonight is the real
housewives of new york so we'll be able
to recap we overcompensate like it just
and love island like it just makes more
sense great i can't wait for all of that
and i think we should get into it
because we need to talk about the
bachelorette because even though we
didn't watch like i do have so many
thoughts on
the blake moreland of it all the black
moreland up and all like to not watch
this season and then to like just swipe
to see who katie chose and it's like
this guy who we know
from the other seasons i'm like the
parker ranger the wildlife manager park
ranger no he's a wildlife manager
i was just like oh so i didn't even need
to watch the season if she's just gonna
pick this guy who we already know is
like pretty thirsty yeah and from what i
gather like thirsty no that's katie's
name katie thurston
um
also like it's funny because i think
the internet has pretty much like
designated katie thurston is like kind
of chewy which i think she is i think
the bachelor franchise in general is
pretty chewy but she's like very much
like side parts skinny jeans um and she
doesn't like she's not good at social
media because she's just like doesn't
care as much like the first picture she
posted with her and blake was like so
blurry vertical with like whites on the
sides like
she needs a social media manager yeah i
saw snatcher posted that and that's just
unacceptable you know i agree like
you've had all year to
learn social media like come on no and
it's like when you get the opport being
the lead of bachelor bachelorette is the
opportunity of a lifetime and because
what comes with it are all of the
followers and you need to rise to the
occasion you need to sustain them and
give the followers premium content yes
that's the job once you're a bachelor
bachelorette or once you win or once you
make it to the very end i always think
of one of the best examples of that is
like vanessa grimaldi and raven gates
that season those girls were kind of
like the last season of girls that got a
million followers just by being in the
top four and i feel like raven has
really um
like cemented herself as like an
influencer like she takes a lot of time
on her content her and adam are like
always working on their content and i
remember watching vanessa grimaldi's
instagram followers drop just because
like she didn't care and so if you go on
the show and like that's your focus
which maybe it's not for everyone it
just seems like a wasted opportunity i
feel like you know michelle's season is
currently filming like katie's a week
from becoming completely irrelevant and
she's putting up blurry you know white
edged photos and it's just not gonna
work yeah i would just say katie look at
me and this opportunity
that's standing right in front of me
now i thought so crazy to me that that
song is going viral on tick tock i know
and i thought that you understood a tick
tock reference but that's not the case
no that's not the case that song is from
annie and it's not the the lead song of
the
of the soundtrack because obviously you
got hard knock life and you get all the
all the
sun will come out but
sia worked on the soundtrack for the
most recent annie and she gave us some
original songs including opportunity
c is so good like justice for zia
justice for sia no she's getting justice
by the fact that that sound is going
viral on tick tock that's true and it's
just this for me you know because that
movie's so good and if you haven't
watched it you definitely should i've
seen it once i don't remember being like
particularly impacted by it but i
remember you like literally like your
life changed after that no here's the
thing i'll explain the thing the thing
is
it's so hard to do a modern take on a
classic tail it is so hard and but when
it's done right there's really nothing
better
and that was annie for sure so it was
just oh my god mr stacks like it was so
good he's like running for me or is
crazy like and just like janae wallace's
mere presence elevates any film and i
think she really did
justice for that role no and she gave an
amazing performance everyone did rose
byrne you know jamie foxx everyone rose
byrne is a good miss hannigan no she
wasn't miss hannigan she was a grace
character miss hannigan was cameron diaz
it's everything of a sort oh right
you know what i feel like i spend a lot
of time thinking about cameron diaz and
has she just totally like
retired and she's probably living her
best life yeah and how just like i think
all the time about how happy i am for
her like she got the bag like she got
shrek she made like 100 million dollars
from track and after that it was all
just
what's the phrase it's all just
like when it's just like extra like
cherry on top like kind of no it's all
just like frosting like no gravy yes
after that like all the great movies she
became like the rom-com star of the
early 2000s and now she's just like
married to one of the madden brothers
can't remember which one has her babies
lives in probably like a fortress and is
so happy yeah and i think she started a
wine company
because i saw that and i was thinking
that too so that's definitely oh i saw
it on dumas and you know what else i saw
on dumas that i'd just like to briefly
talk about
somebody spotted sarah jessica parker
and they were like she's out to lunch
like with her kids or whatever she's
reading a pink book
with black writing
now i'm just saying it's entirely
possible it's not out of the realm of
possibility is it high probability no
but it's possible that she was reading
my new york times bestselling book girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram thirst monster available as
kindle audiobook hardcover anywhere
amazon barnes and noble indie bookstores
check it out because it might be sarah
jessica parker approved unless you don't
like it it might be oh that's true but
then she wouldn't be seen reading it
publicly yeah i know i'm just like i
really want to know if anyone who wrote
that in
like is a toaster like please let me
know what the book was or do you have a
picture of it or something i think it's
better here's the thing it probably
wasn't your book if we're being honest
that is so hurtful if we're being honest
yeah it's important to be honest so i
think it's better to not know because
then you can always live on the dream
that it was your book okay
also i just want to talk about one other
movie that's just in this rolodex of
movies that live rem free in my mind
along with bad teacher mm-hmm annie the
wedding ringer have you seen that movie
i think you might be
a big cameron dias okay but not in the
third one wait the wedding ring girl
with kevin hart and josh gad oh my god
yeah of course that's where where kaylee
cuoco is like such a [ __ ] yes okay
every single time i'm at a wedding and a
rehearsal dinner and there's the
speeches i think of the wedding ringer i
ask everyone at the table if they've
seen it nobody [ __ ] has so you all
need to watch this movie because you
can't go to a wedding without watching
it it's such a good movie
jackie you're the only person who like
quotes that movie but it is really good
no but i don't remember like anything
all that i remember was that like josh
gad was take getting taken advantage of
by kelly cuoco and kevin hart was like
hired to be better he's a groomsman for
hire for guys who don't have no friends
which was like the whole movie was just
like josh had being sad and i really
didn't like it but he comes out on top
and i don't want to spoil anything and
it's also such a good movie just about
like wedding etiquette you know because
kevin hart has been to a million
weddings and he knows exactly how it
goes and he's like you know the best man
who takes out his speech and then rips
it up like you know you don't want to be
that guy you guys have to watch the
wedding ring or like if you're in
wedding season of your life because i'm
so sick of bringing it up at weddings
and no one's seen it you know what a
table what movie i always bring up at
weddings table 19 because i'm like
always katelyn
teen 19. 19. yeah yeah because i'm like
always at like a random table i'm like
this is like table 19. like you're her
accountant like i'm her best friend like
why am i sitting i know but that was
like a weird indie movie and just like
the odds that people have seen that are
even smaller really yeah i don't even
think it was in theaters
but anna kendrick was in it i know and i
don't think she's like proud of it or
anything but it's a really good movie
and a good premise it's like she's at a
wedding of her ex-boyfriend and she's at
like the miscellaneous table with like
the other people they didn't know where
to seat and all of these people like go
on a journey together yeah it was cute
like it wasn't the best movie ever
but i think of it when i go to um
weddings where i'm seated at like a
random table because like i'm like not
really like friends like you know yeah
yeah no exactly so those are two movies
that you should watch before you go to a
wedding and then you'll you know you'll
be set you'll be laughing to yourself
because i'm oh like i was at a wedding
and someone like took out their speech
and ripped it up and i was like [ __ ]
seen wedding ringer
that must be frustrating for you yeah
it's thank you all right so check those
out um i feel like we should dive in
because we're definitely gonna have a
long show we've got your toasters lots
to talk about and i feel comfortable
i feel comfortable diving in you feel
comfortable getting right into it yeah
okay so without further ado it is time
for the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
lug lug lug lug lug hydro jug hydration
made easy
okay you guys the benefits of drinking
water are endless it can improve your
energy your mental clarity clear your
skin and just help with your overall
wellness but over 75 of americans are
dehydrated and i'm definitely one of
them water is so crucial to your health
every cell and tissue inside of your
body requires water to function so
a hydro jug might be the thing you need
because sometimes it's easy to forget
about drinking water but a hydro drug
keeps you on it keeps you accountable
keeps you on schedule the hydro jug
features a half a gallon of water with a
leak proof seal and a wide mouth opening
it also has a carry loop so it makes it
super easy to carry
and on the sides of the bottle has a
measurement scale so you know how much
progress you're making every day with
how much water you're drinking um it's
totally dishwasher safe the bottle is
shatter proof and um they have a sleeve
that insulates your
content so it keeps your water cool and
it protects your hydra jog and then it
also has two pockets one for your phone
and then another one for like smaller
accessories like your air pods it also
comes with adjustable straps you can
carry your hydro jug because they can be
very heavy um which is even more of an
incentive to drink it so it gets lighter
um so they're easy to clean easy to
reuse because they're dishwasher safe
and just one person switching to a
reusable water bottle saves
approximately 217 plastic water bottles
from going into a landfill so if you
want to check it out you've been meaning
to get on the hydro drug chain so many
celebrities do it it's like the cool
thing now you got to get a hydro jog
check out hydrodrug at the hydro jug.com
and use the discount code toast to get
10 off your order today the hype is real
hydra drugs are game changers for anyone
on the go use code toast at the hydro
jug.com to get 10 off today and start
hydrating in style i've been very vocal
about how like i literally cannot drink
water but a hydro drug is just so big
and obvious it's like in your face like
drink me drink me [ __ ] and i definitely
feel like it's effective i've started
drinking so much more water and using
less plastic which is always great we
were talking earlier about how we really
need to commit to some self-care this
week because a lot of things have just
fallen by the wayside and you know doing
a hydro jug filling it up getting it
done which is like so much makes it like
fun you know it's like yeah it's a
gamifies drinking water
i think that's the best place for us to
start i mean i'm definitely on the
self-care journey with you but i'm so
focused on moving like literally i had
such a mishap with my freezer like the
freezer just turned off because like it
felt like it and everything in my
freezer melted like i spent like 300 on
kosher meat useless i got to throw it
all out so annoying um so i'm just like
on this journey to get out of my
apartment like that's where my focus is
i spent all day yesterday like on all
these websites and i've officially seen
every apartment and there's nothing out
there for me but i actually got a
message from a toaster who was like me
and my husband are moving but like we
think we're gonna rent out our apartment
or maybe sell it like if you like it
like let me know and it's not my desired
location but it is beautiful and it does
have the outdoor space i was talking
about like more than just a terrace like
uh
outdoor living space it's more like a
garden um
and it was just like an off-market
moment and i was like so
like
frederick ecklung like off-market like
hudas so i don't know i feel like i'm
gonna become an off-market girly but
then i was like googling off market
apartment but like they're off market
for a reason so you can't find them so
if anyone has any off-market rentals
like hit me up yeah you got to put the
call out there yeah like off-market i'm
here like i'm i'm on market gotta get
off so will somebody just get me a
boarding pass off market no seriously
like i'll take anything everyone's like
where do you want to live i'm like i
don't care like i'm going to try back
like i don't think if that was true then
you would have taken the toaster up in
her apartment now yeah except wow
totally except like that happens to me
in one area like i really don't want to
be in okay okay fine but i'm still open
to it
you're moving to tribeca i'll
i'll do it i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
sure no i'll have a try back i'll leave
it when i see it
okay you'll have like a 30 minute
commute to work every day literally what
else am i doing
that's true okay are you ready to get
into the stories because the first one
is the big news of this tuesday which is
that the bachelorette star katie
thurston got engaged to blake moines
last night on the bachelorette finale
for those of us who did not watch this
season and who just woke up to the news
that she was engaged to blake
what in the world transpired it also
made like confirmed my
like
desire to not watch this season because
now it's like oh i didn't miss anything
i know blake he's you know the thirsty
one from clarentia season who will say
anything to stay on this [ __ ]
show and look his talents got him far
enough i had her whispers that he had
like come back because he was like you
know you know very taken by katie i
didn't even know he was still around so
like when i was like i was looking
really hard for a spoiler on twitter and
i guess people on twitter really respect
the time zone west coast spoiler alert
because i couldn't find [ __ ] and then of
course who had it no
the click bait queen just jared had it
and i was like blake there's no way like
that's so random especially because like
what i from what i was gathering on
twitter was that
she ended like at the top five or four
with like really really great guys and
it's like a hannah brown situation like
you have tyler c but you choose jed and
it's like you have all these guys and
you choose blake for my understanding of
not watching the show but just seeing um
like headlines here and there and i saw
a commercial last night so her this guy
greg was number three and i think like
everybody's obsessed with greg and i
think katie was too but then he like
left on his own volition which just goes
to show you he's not he's here for the
wrong reasons and he doesn't like you
and he got way too far and like he
didn't know what to do with himself to
me when someone leaves at top three like
that
uh that is the biggest [ __ ] red flag
because it's it means that you were not
here for the love like you got further
than you wanted to if shit's getting
serious and you want out like i don't
have to watch and maybe if i watch the
show i would feel differently but like
when i just see it like that you know
i'm like oh you weren't here for the
right reasons that's so interesting you
couldn't take this charade any further i
think sometimes i do feel that way about
a lot of people especially the guys
because like for a girl whatever like if
even if you're not obsessed with a guy
like being in a relationship's not the
biggest deal but for some guys it's like
scary i i agree but i think the overall
thing with greg was like he was so
infatuated with katie that he couldn't
handle this environment anymore he was
so close to the end the environment was
ending totally totally
so anyways the vibe that i was getting
from just the
press was that
greg was her number one he left and so
she has to choose between these two guys
i think it was blake and the other guy's
name
was i don't know justin justin is the
other guy and so she chose blake and i
it does feel a little bit like maybe the
editing made it seem like it was a
consolation since she wasn't over greg i
don't even [ __ ] watch so i don't know
and i'm sure like they're
in love and all's good i just can't
believe it's [ __ ] like moylan like no
i know
literally
in shock i was expecting to see like new
guy i've never seen you know i know and
it's blake moylan and for those of you
who don't know i've been really been on
a journey with my feelings towards like
because when he first showed up on
claire's season i really thought he was
such a catch i thought he was so cute
and like nobody thought much of him but
like you had like were really kind of
taken by i was taken by him like he's a
wildlife manager which i think is a
stranger such a important
job you know and like
just pretty cool and he's super handsome
and i was like okay this size seems like
you know legit what is this super
handsome
well now that i know like for me people
just look like their
so like you're trying to go back to who
i was so what do i look like to you the
most beautiful angel alive
um wait did you just call me ugly
my personality makes me look pretty even
if it's no i know you're saying if
you're ugly and you have an ugly
personality you look ugly if you're
pretty and you have an ugly personality
you look ugly if you're ugly and you
have a pretty personality it's mixed
no i'm kidding yeah no i agree with you
it's more so like for guys too like even
when i watch love island like i stop
seeing the what they look like and i'm
just like the things they say 100
okay and that's on not being shallow so
what was i saying about blake
my journey the environment my journey
with him so at first i was like he seems
like a really good catch and like a
strong contender and then like
everything got weird and then tasha came
and he like brought that same you know
devoted energy to tasha that he brought
to claire and i was like you can't be so
devoted wait
isn't it kind of weird
that like tasha is hosting a season with
a guy she used to date yeah i didn't
think about it i didn't think about that
either but it's it's weird so now he's
on his third bachelorette he's bringing
that same devotion and i'm sorry you
just can't be like that gung-ho about
three different girls no but you're that
gung-ho about being on television yeah
cause all the girls look so different
and act so different like not everyone
can be your type you're not gonna fall
in love with everyone and if you do like
what's wrong with you so like when i
heard he was going on this on this
season i was just like okay confirms
like my suspicions that make he just
wants to be on television and will
really date anyone but you know his
talents have gotten pretty far because
now he's engaged that's crazy
like what
what i agree and like
i don't know i just don't really like
jive with
the engagement yeah and i just like i'm
not feeling it i'm not buying it but i
didn't watch a season so maybe i'm
missing something yeah actually from
i've been trying to just like gather
intel on how people are feeling and
people are really divided it's either
like biggest waste of my time or like
wow this is actually a really like
earnest genuine season i don't know how
you could think both of those things
like i don't know that is why i need to
listen to the snatcher today like i have
no desire to watch any of this content
but i just want to know what the snitch
thinks because
she she doesn't hold back that snitch
can we talk about now like you know in
hindsight how the journey the decision
that we made to not watch a bachelorette
like how do you think that was for us i
feel so at peace with my decision not
for one minute did i look back regret it
i had seen some comments that were like
you guys chose the wrong season to skip
like you've got to be watching katie
season and i've just never felt that way
um i won't be watching michelle's season
because i i'm pretty much done with and
also whoever is the next bachelor will
have come from one of these seasons and
i don't watch i don't know him um but i
will still be watching bachelor in
paradise because
that's usually a fun show which leads
into our next story if you're ready for
it yeah
bachelorette former bachelorette becca
kufrin is taking to season seven of
bachelor in paradise last night they
aired a promo for the new season and we
will see her on the beach she reunites
with joe grocery store joe who was on
her season oh my god um and that's just
really crazy i believe
i need to think i believe too i think
she is the first lead to go on bachelor
in paradise after being the lead because
nick was on and then became the lead
colton was on then became the leader
that's not what i'm saying the only
graduate like
and to me it's weird because i remember
before
you know chris soules
killed someone yes had that tragic
accident he was supposed to go on
bachelor in paradise yes and i remember
thinking that was really curious
i remember thinking that was really cute
because i was like he really wants to
find love and he should go on the beach
and all these girls like he doesn't even
know them anymore like
it was a few seasons yeah
and but now like with when becca's doing
it i'm like this is really sad like oh
how the mighty have fallen yes so i
think generally
there is a huge hierarchy within
bachelor in paradise whereas like some
contestants are so lucky to get on
paradise like lacey mark like literally
so grateful for the opportunity
and they're not too good for it they're
actually like not good enough for it you
know and then there are some contestants
within the hierarchy who would never
even like
of course she's like married but like
lauren lane like whatever you know what
i mean like
you you either are too good for it you
graduate out of the franchise or there's
just like not even a remote possibility
no or there are the people who are like
the perfect paradise people it's usually
the runner-up they get so much respect
hannity raven raven um even the men it's
harder with the men because usually the
season of bachelor in paradise is filmed
too close to the season of the
bachelorette so the guy who's second
still has a chance of being the bachelor
and he doesn't want to go on bathroom
holidays and that always [ __ ] with the
ratio of good girls to good guys because
we're just getting these like guys who
were sent home week one and all these
girls who were like runner-ups golden
eggs golden girls yeah i agree but so
the fact that there's a lead going on is
so bizarre to me because she really
she's she's very popular within the
franchise she's the host of the bachelor
happy hour podcast so she's obviously
very high ranked in this hierarchy
i think it's so bizarre but you're right
like it's definitely case by case
because like when chris soules was gonna
go on like definitely so cute but like
crystals there's just something like
pjummy about him and he never like
chased anything after
the show the show like he just like went
back to his farm so it was like kind of
earnest was like becca's like a
full-flown full-fledged podcaster
influencer
full-time working within bachelor nation
like i do think this is weird i think
this is weird
i really do like she's going to be on
the beach like grocery store joe with
like guys that
she
wrote off wrote off that she now has to
like reconsider yeah that would be so
weird no it's
it's not normal i i i think it's weird
i think it's weird but you know what i
would feel that way i got paid so much
like who was a single bachelor
who didn't work out with their nick
viall
no but he's in a relationship now he is
oh yeah um
let me think we're the bachelor's colton
he's single
but who was after colton
my brain's not working okay wait so
colton
got off of becca's susan and runner up
was hannah brown hannah brown's season
produced
colt
hannah brown season produced peter peter
the pilot perfect example okay if peter
the pilot was going on bachelor in
paradise i would think it's weird okay
if peter the pilot was going on bachelor
paradise i would literally take a
baseball bat to my television just
because i've never met someone who's so
unlikable on television in my entire
life who's has such poor decision skills
when it comes to his love life and went
on a show about his love life i would
not watch if peter the pilot went on i'm
just letting you know also what the hell
happened between him and kelly i don't
know but he had the worst season ever
and we got no explanation
wait he went from hannah ann to madison
what's her name
matty maddie pruitt yeah maddie back to
hannah and then to kelly
when kelly was always the answer
he was he was he got engaged to hannah
ann on the show how fun he chose hannah
yeah
and then switched to maddie
yeah and then ended up with kelly
right when like all along we thought it
was kelly who was number three because
kelly went home four yeah who was number
three
i don't know who was the bachelorette
after peter webber
okay so kelly kelsey weir
it was probably the last season we went
oh claire
oh my god
it's just too much it's too much this is
hurting my brain this exercise no just
take me back to like the
caitlyn bristow days the jojo fletcher
the ben higgins like those were the days
those were the days and i'm still gonna
watch bachelor and party paradise and i
do think like becca's
presence will be an interesting thing
considering like let's see who's there
like is blake um
block alley
blocky yeah what sportsman like if he's
there he's becca's runner-up
like i guess he's not going i'm pretty
sure he said he was done with the
franchise like sorry as he should be one
of his q and a's but like that's that's
just so crazy anyways it will be
interesting to watch but i just feel
like for her i can't believe she's doing
this i hope she got paid a lot of money
me too because like technically she is
better than this
yeah she's just like she had the coveted
position that so many people would love
to have in within the franchise like
was a lead tons of followers tapped to
host the official bachelorette podcast
like i can't imagine why she would take
this step down also like
realistically if there's anybody from
the franchise that she's interested in
like she can dm them and meet them so is
she going on for love the paycheck or
the followers i also feel like
the bachelor and bachelorette franchise
is so bizarre because so many different
seasons like really kind of target
different age groups and i don't know if
like the guys coming off of katie's
season
are age-appropriate for becca mm-hmm
so it's just for me guys from claire
season are
yeah but they were also young yes
yes it'll really be mixed
it'll be so bizarre
when did they film bachelor in paradise
because i don't know but they have
stills coming out of everyone on the
beach they we saw david spade first look
that'll be weird to see yeah i probably
am going to watch bachelor in paradise
also because love island's almost over
and like you'll have a whole isn't it
crazy how like i don't mind watching
one hour five times a week of
love island but two hours of the
bachelor is just unreasonable i think
that is it is unreasonable also a little
love island update i don't know if you
saw but like a lot of the castmates who
have been voted off did an instagram
live last night cash and cinco were
together and they were instagram living
with amy and wes who are still together
and like cash and cinco were like making
out on the live like they're fully
together it's crazy that there's more
couples outside of the villa than there
are inside and that's a problem that
they have to fix for next season agreed
because people like amy and wes should
have been held on to people like cash
and cinco should have been given an
opportunity to rekindle even though i do
blame cash for that they were given the
option she was given and even though he
did [ __ ] around she chose not to be with
him and so she had to sleep in the bed
she lied even though she was her heart
was visinco yeah i agree but you're
right there is a problem that all these
couples are on the outside
are you ready for our next story which
is a little more couple news a little
more couple news that's brought to you
by nuts.com the best kept secret of
savvy snackers across the country yes
and we are savvy snackers so we would
know the best kept secret nuts.com isn't
just for nut lovers it's your one stop
online pantry shop
they have an incredible variety of
snacks and pantry items including
candies dried fruits pantry items like
baking mixes pasta and more it's so much
more than nuts even though some of their
candied nuts are so heavenly like
endless um so it's a simple and
convenient way to have nutritious
delicious healthy nuts dried fruits
flowers grains and so many other high
quality foods delivered straight to your
door they have over 4000 products to
choose from including delicious healthy
kid-friendly snacks like dried
strawberries and custom trail mix plus
they have all the raw organic roasted
salted and candied nuts that you can
imagine even chocolate dipped which are
delightful the website's super easy to
navigate they have great photos of all
the products it's a family-run business
that takes pride in getting you the
freshest
ingredients possible
nuts.com is your one-stop online pantry
shop with gluten-free and vegan options
their delivery is super fast because
most of their orders ship the same day
and they have fresher products than the
supermarket new nuts.com customers can
get free shipping on your first order
when you text toast to six sixty four
thousand that's toast to sixty four
thousand so text toast to sixty 64 000
to get free shipping on your first order
from nuts.com that's toast to 64 000
terms apply available at nuts.com terms
um check it out like sometimes if you're
just like in a rut with your snacks you
just need to elevate to like more
refined it's also great for parties it's
very elegant but also really good
tasting check it out we have so many
here in our studio they keep us going
they keep us going we nuts are so good
for your energy we run on nuts.com we're
nuts for nuts
our next story a little new couple news
lily rose depp and austin butler were
caught in a lip lock out in london
johnny depp's daughter with model
vanessa parade was swoo snapped over the
weekend wait what what she was snapped
over the line again johnny depp's
daughter with the model it was a weird
way which model vanessa parody that's
the that's lily vs mom oh that's so
funny i don't know why like
at all like i have no explanation for
this like why i just assume that lily
rose
depp's
mom was chaos like i don't know
they look alike they do but like i had
no proof and i actually never really sat
down and thought about it just knew she
was like a famous kid yeah and i'm like
depp oh yeah johnny depp
she does look like kate moss that's kmos
i think that's like and she's like a
really up-and-coming model and like she
lives in london i like for sure thought
that her mom was kate was
that's funny
kate moss
yeah you learn something new every day
but her mom's a nobody's what you're
saying she's a model maybe in her day
but i'm unfamiliar with her work she was
snapped over the weekend locked in an
embrace with the switched at birth actor
austin butler in london following a
dinner date for those of you who don't
know austin butler he used the x how
dare you he's the ex of vanessa hudgins
they dated for such a long time that was
a lot to digest and he's from the carrie
diaries he played the love interest and
he's just like a great actor and i and
he also just got cast in that elvis
bible yeah
he got the the job a million girls
wanted oh he beat out harry styles harry
styles ansel elgort and miles teller for
the role of elvis presley in like this
bad lerman biopic that's coming out
whenever and he's so handsome and he's
always blonde but then he went brown and
then you could really see him as elvis
and he's gonna be a big star i'm just
like actually a really big austin butler
fan mostly because i loved the carrie
diaries like i thought they were such an
underrated show right it was like a
prequel tv show about saxon city like
anna sophia rob played carrie in high
school it was so good he was also in
once upon a time in hollywood like one
day austin butler is going to be a name
we don't have to explain so and so
honestly like when him and vanessa
hudgins broke up i just kind of want to
take you through my journey vanessa anne
um i was like devastated because i
thought these were like true otp i
thought they were really well matched i
thought that there was so much proof in
how long they'd been together they were
they weren't thirsty they were just like
a good couple solid and i was kind of
devastated when they broke up and then
after they broke up like vanessa ann
just like really went downhill like
making really bad decisions like that
weird video that she made she was the
first person to get canceled during
coven and then i just feel like she just
like dropped the ball on her career in a
lot of ways and i was like you know what
i think maybe they're breaking up was
the best thing for us in butler because
he has a really big bright future ahead
of him and now him being with lily rose
kate moss's daughter i think this is so
sick like so great i'm thrilled that's
my personal journey with this story if
you want to share yours no for me i
agree with most of what you said my only
concern here is like that they're not in
a relationship no that they're not in a
relationship but that they like were
just like kissed and we happen to see it
yeah you want to get our hopes up yeah i
don't know if like this is a [ __ ]
building exercise because the pictures
were not like they didn't look staged no
they looked like just steamy like you
know had a drink needed to make out
austin butler was here he's 29 and she's
22. did you have a concern about their
age
no
like okay obviously
no like compared to what i see in
hollywood she's 22 she's an adult
and 29 i mean that's really not crazy no
compared to what we've seen in hollywood
that's extremely age-appropriate you
know and i really believe like if you're
22 like you are able to make your own
decisions and she's deciding to be in a
relationship with someone someone who's
29. i don't think that's crazy if they
were 32 and 39 would we say anything no
right i think it's fine yeah i think
it's fine i think it's a cute couple i
don't want to get my hopes up but i
think it's really cute it makes a lot of
sense but also she was previously linked
to timothy chalmet yeah and i think a
lot of people had a lot of ships out for
them and i didn't i don't no i don't at
all i actually think like if his career
goes the way that we think it's gonna go
and he is like
dating lily rose depp
that is hollywood like royalty in the
making like i can't even think of who i
would compare to it's like uh
brad and angelina like even though she's
not like an actress you know what i mean
like it's a true power couple yeah i
agree well i'm so excited for them when
i saw those pictures i was like really
excited it was like a very unstaged
steamy messy right like it was not sexy
like it was like kind of gross but like
in a good way like they're having a good
time yeah no i'm really
too young to successful people i cannot
wait for that elvis thing like i i hope
he kills it like i'm really rooting for
him me too we were rooting for you we
were all rooting for you are you ready
for our next story which is even more
couple news about one of claudia's i
think least favorite people oh my god
you have so many yeah i know you
wouldn't be able to guess
brooks leach
is going instagram official monster he's
has a new leading lady in his life just
one week after being spotted out with
packing on the pda brooks lake is going
public on instagram
with his new relationship the former nhl
player and former husband of julianne
huff uh posted a picture she deserves so
much better than that
at the four seasons resort in hawaii
where the couple arrived last week for
romantic getaway in the photo leich and
his new girlfriend who is also an
athlete her name is katrine walk toward
each other from opposite sides of the
infinity pool pretty cool and artsy it
does make you wonder who took the
picture um totally like the poor bellman
like another one was still h like mr
lage germany do you need me to take mr
lights you like this angle
yeah exactly i mean honestly like i have
so much hate in my heart for this person
and i don't even know him like all i
know is
him from the purview of the julian half
situation like i don't even know what
sport he plays i don't care i don't know
i don't want to know
i'm i love like the how little
information i have on him like
he just seemed so thirsty to me for
someone who was supposed to be like a
supportive husband you know yeah i
thought he was the main character it was
supposed to be about julianne yeah he
thought he was the main character in a
relationship where julianne was clearly
the star and i'm sorry in these types of
like famous relationships most of the
time unless you're both a-listers which
they are not there is one star and
there's one supporting man and or
supporting person and he just thought it
was him and it's not no it's not and
this story actually makes me happy
because for a while there i was like are
brooks leitch and giuliana like getting
back together no i hope not
so i don't think that they are and this
is good because i need julian to like
move on to bigger and better things
maybe ryan seacrest is single again no i
really kind of shipped her and even
though they never dated they just did a
movie together josh dumel and he's
single
oh i don't see that at all i feel like
cute
sure that would be cute but i just don't
see it i think literally i don't know if
any person in hollywood has a worse
track record in terms of dating than
julianne huff why
brook slach ryan seacrest like come on
ryan seacrest is cool that's very cool
compatibility no no
i just think like she doesn't have a
good track record like if she let us set
her up with someone we could
kill it
who would you set her up with
derek
their names are always together because
their brother and sister you know
julia and derek they sound like they're
married you know i
exactly what i was gonna say like i just
think optics wise their life would be so
much better if they were mr and mrs huff
instead of brother and sister huff like
they have similar interests they're like
both equally good looking like i
actually think they are the perfect
couple yeah
in like a
different kind of way in a different
world yeah
exactly it's just something to think
about that's what's new with brooks
lynch
i know you never miss an opportunity to
say his name no it brooks if you had not
brought him up i probably would not have
thought of his name for like another 15
years and that would have hurt you
that's how like irrelevant he is yeah i
know but i still think that like their
wedding is one of the most beautiful
i've seen like the lake the boat her
dress
i think about it all the time think
about it all the time it was like the
dream wedding and it made me mad that i
didn't get married on the lake yeah and
no when i saw those pictures and it was
before i ever got married and it was
just like a bummer knowing like no
matter what i do that would never be my
wedding because that's just like not who
i am theo's eating your clif bar there's
nothing in there oh okay he's just
wanting to know what flavor auntie had
okay she had chocolate chip okay if
anyone wanted to know he's like what the
[ __ ]
um all right well thank you for ruining
my day i really couldn't do this job
without you
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a little apt casting news
captain news yeah catherine zeta jones
has been cast as morticia wait catherine
zeta jones has been kept oh okay in
wednesday adam's netflix series i mean
obviously yeah catherine zeta jones is
about to get scary the oscar winner has
recently been casted it's morticia in
the upcoming wednesday adams series on
netflix the actress will star in the
eight episode series alongside cast
members jenna ortega and luis guzman
ortega will start as wednesday and
guzman will play gomez adams morticia's
husband luis guzman from how to make it
in america such an underrated actor like
his show got cancelled how to make it in
america he's so talented i just wanted
to put that out there yeah this is like
also just exciting there's going to be
like an adams family mini series coming
to netflix i'm sure it will be extremely
well done i feel like a lot of people
really like part of their personality
complex is like wednesday adams and the
addams family can i ask you a question
when you think of the adams family what
do you think of
um i don't know if what i'm going to say
is like what you're thinking
so the song the adam's family there's
olivia and margo claudia and jackie
they're all a little wacky the ashrae
family
it's really cute i that that had not
re-entered my brain and oh it's all i
think when i think of that because i've
actually
this is like a personality thing i don't
even know what the adams family is i've
never seen one morsel of it i think it
was a little bit before my time and like
i know nothing about it and what's the
difference between
wednesday adams
and like
the girl from the orphan like i don't i
don't like that whole thing like i can't
i don't understand it no it's it's just
not something we've ever delved into
like because it's just a little spooky
and like you said before our time
wednesday adams has the braids and the
middle part and she's like grumpy at
camp right wait what
and then there's the movie the orphan
where the girl literally wears braids
and wears the white collar and it's like
is this part of the addams family i
don't know
no that's not and so there's the adams
family but wednesday adams is a star and
she has her own show like i just don't
get it i don't get it either but i think
that maybe this series is meant for us
like we could have like a little
experience with the addams family
catherine zeta jones would be real it's
like looks just like the mom yeah in a
premium way
yeah so that's pretty cool and i'm happy
for all the addams family stands out
there who are going to be getting this
premium content because there's a lot of
people yeah for sure like people who are
obsessed with murder
yeah or like wednesday adam's you know
halloween costume yep where you're like
with the part like that yeah yeah so
that's your apt casting news for the day
captain news um all right the show is
not even close to being over because
we've got deer toasters which is so
exciting
and dear toast is brought to you by
betterhelp is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
betterhelp is here to assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
better help is not a crisis line it is
not self-help it is professional therapy
done securely online the service is
available for clients worldwide where
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your therapist
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule a weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in an uncomfortable
waiting room as you do with traditional
therapy
better help is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change therapists if
needed it's more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today visit their website if you want to
read some of their testimonials they're
posted daily and visit betterhelp.com
toast that's better h-e-l-p to join the
over a million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional and
if you go to that link betterhelp.com
toast you'll get 10 off your first month
so the special offer for the morning
toast listeners is 10 off your first
month at betterhelphelp.comtoast
thank you all right we have two
submissions and an update from someone i
know you're going to be really excited
to hear from oh my god i'm so excited
but first
excuse me
our submissions hey claudia and jackie
this deer toasters email has been a long
time coming my friend and i listen to
the podcast every day during work of
course and it's basically just the best
thing ever well here it goes i had these
two besties at work we literally did
everything together i was 20 weeks
pregnant with my second child and i
couldn't decide on her name i was
between let's just say olivia and margo
for her names okay such amazing
beautiful names and i decided to share
the names with the co-workers uh oh big
mistake huge they said both are super
cute names we love them the weekend
before i was getting induced i finally
decided on the name margo
saturday afternoon one of the girls
snaps a picture of a new puppy she got
what
my other bff and i were ecstatic for her
and asked her what she's going to name
the puppy she replies we're thinking
margot i literally died inside i said
are you joking
she's like no fred her douchey husband
who controls everything really likes it
i replied don't you think it's kind of
weird considering i'm naming my baby
girl margot on monday
no reply
fast forward to sunday she hasn't
dropped the name i finally text her and
say i have to be honest this really
hurts me that you're going to use the
exact same name i've told you about for
five months can you find another name
there's literally a million she posted a
picture of her puppy sunday night on her
insta and the name and everything before
i even had my baby am i overreacting
what am i supposed to do would love any
help this girl's a [ __ ] [ __ ] a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're not overreacting um
no you're under-reacting this girl's
disgusting disgusting but you know what
it's actually
it's fine like now you've seen her true
colors like that is such a disrespectful
thing to do reminds me of shep rose
naming his dog craig just like so
disgusting like still affects me and me
too i think about it all the time and
every time the little craig is on the
show i'm just like oh wow you did that
to your friend like so wrong
so
i would um just cut this person out of
your life
because it might not like first of all
it's it is a big deal and it's also
indicative of such a
terrible person like she obviously has
no character she has no backbone if her
husband's like bossing her around for
the dog's name and she knows where she
got it from like she's spineless i hate
this woman hey and i just want to also
say like
don't not using this this is for
everyone out there
please stop using beautiful human names
for dogs yeah i agree sometimes i think
about how like i really regret naming
things that wasn't an attack on you no
but i think i've said that before i
think i was having this conversation
recently with margaret olivia i
love the name theodore and like i would
love to name like my kid theodore one
day and like because actually not
theodore like theo yeah but like i took
it yeah it's no his name okay should
have been movie okay no no it just
should have been um
archie but archie's also a great name
for me
i love the name archie but wait
but hear me out it's disrespectful to
name
a dog after a person but is it
disrespectful to name a person after the
dog
i just think it shouldn't be done like
right that's why we need like just
delineation like keep it like the dog
names human names yeah but but i also
feel like when you chose theo it was
right before that name popped off again
no i'm so like trendy it's disgusting
yeah no it's really true like you you
didn't know it's not it's not like if
you chose it today yeah no i'm that's
one thing because he's so grown and big
but like this girl this girl
how about this you brought back the name
theo
it was a self-fulfilling like
trendsetter yeah trendsetter i just i
have to really stress like this this
girl is so disgusting if you ever talk
to her again like i'll be so
disappointed in you to have a dog named
margo is so weird marco's like a
fabulous girl who goes to france like
and she eats croissant like
french dog like it just makes no sense
it makes no sense and also like this is
why you shouldn't be friends with your
co-workers no this is why you shouldn't
tell people what you're thinking for
baby names
i didn't know what it was going to be
when you said this story like i knew it
was going to be a problem i didn't know
it was going to be a dog which takes us
like a whole other level of disrespect
but the first mistake you made
was telling your coworkers that you were
going between the names olivia and
margot yep and they're your co-workers
and you don't even know them
yeah absolutely not you have to take a
little bit of responsibility for you
bringing this on yourself yeah and i
understand like being friends with your
co-workers sometimes you can't help
yourself
someone at work and like they just
happened to be your friend person you
know like you literally met your husband
at work right and then i left the job
yeah as you should you just shouldn't
[ __ ] where you eat a grape you just
should not and i also didn't like the
job but yeah still i would have left so
you were fired
no i wasn't she wasn't no i wasn't um
you were fired from your next shop
the morning breath no no that was two
jobs later okay all right next up good
morning jackie and claudia this week i
started a new job and i already found
myself in a pickle thinking what would
claudia and jackie have to say about
this on monday i started a position in a
new hotel in manhattan set to open in
september oh i'm going to find out what
hotels can we get a free room penthouse
it's a dream role especially after after
losing my last event sales hotel job due
to cobid side note i'm the
toaster who worked with claudia oh i
know her
i don't want to um blow up her spot i
don't want to blow her spot but i know
her i've worked with this girl the new
hotel is still under construction on
monday i stopped on a bench to change
from my flats into my work heels on the
one of the construction workers told me
good luck on the interview to which i
replied thank you i already got the job
it's my first day
wednesday i arrived with two large bags
so this same guy walked over to open the
door for me he told me his name and i
said thank you and shared my name as
well four hours later i received an
email that a package has arrived for me
i walked down to the lobby to three
dozen long stem roses with a card from
him while incredibly flattering i was
mortified now i had this crazy
extravagant floral arrangement
to put on my desk at a job i'd been at
for under a week with no good
explanation where it came from i'm very
afraid everyone's going to think the new
girl slutting it up on her first week
with the construction crew i did text
the guy thank you for the flowers he
included his number in the card and now
he asked me to launch i don't think i'm
attracted to this man and i couldn't
pick him out of a police lineup if my
life depended on it i'm going to see him
every morning until the hotel's
completed do i shut it down give it a
chance please assist a corporate
hospitality first of all you must be i
you must be like the most like charming
like yeah nothing to be beautiful but to
have men just like falling over that
doesn't happen anymore and that like
here's the thing i wanted before we dive
in like i want you to like pat yourself
on the back i just want to say like
this story in some context like is
extremely romantic the beginning of a
hallmark movie also creepy but these
things don't happen in new york and even
when he said good luck on the interview
i was like who even and then you said
it's not you guys like had a
conversation like that just doesn't
happen in new york no i agree and so
like
i think
the you know the dreamer in me is like
how beautiful but the
realistic cynic in me is like this is
dangerous like this doesn't we should be
like we're so jaded like this should be
romantic it's weird no it's weird in
this city yeah no it's just not normal
people don't just talk to people they've
never met and send flowers
right like that just doesn't happen
maybe this guy's like a diamond in the
wrap like a really old soul
but i'm inclined to just go with creepy
yeah no i agree just because of like the
odds being in new york and like what
like it's just also i feel you like that
you like are embarrassed like by these
big flowers at your desk throw them out
like for sure oh no i think that's so
cool
everyone would be like oh my god she's
so fabulous and you clearly are fabulous
so it's like you're the girl who like no
you're clearly stunted on these
co-workers like i just teach me your
ways like it's not even about like
physical appearances you also have to be
like have this confidence and like this
charm just like have people like dazzled
by you yeah i'm i'm highly impressed
okay but her question her question was
she do like how does she like how does
she go forward because she's not
interested in him but he's going to be
working outside the hotel every single
day
take the back door yeah work from home
look for a side entrance
i'm just like operating under the guys
that it's like
you know this isn't a hallmark movie
it's a lifetime so you have a husband
but it's not hallmark it's lifetime oh
my god no it's one or the other and like
i don't think we're gonna know which one
it is but you're not even interested in
him so it doesn't even matter yeah take
the back door
yeah or you just start sleeping at the
sitting at the hotel so you never have
to leave just get by whatever get over
there get a room sleep there work you
never have to leave
and then the construction will be done
before you know it
yeah all right finally this is our
update from a girl that i know you've
been thinking like she's been living
rent-free in your mind oh my god
jackie and claudia i have an update for
you for a refresher i'm the girl that
was contemplating joe with his cattle
ranch or my current boyfriend that i had
been with for six years i can truly say
that you guys changed my life and i'm so
grateful for your toasters yeah
after listening to you answer my
question on the podcast i realized that
i was indeed more in love with the idea
of joe than joe himself like she was she
was more hooked about like living on a
ranch 100
also claudia was right and i liked his
cattle ranch more than i liked the man
after hearing your third party
perspective it allowed me to take a step
back and realize how great my existing
relationship was we've since hung out
with joe and i now realize he's nothing
of the sword and i had my ranch goggles
on
that's what we said
thanks to jackie's advice about being on
the same page about family and kids we
were able to sit down and have a
discussion fast forward a little over a
year we just got married in july we now
live on our own cattle ranch
with cows horses dogs and cats and have
plans to start trying to get pregnant
next spring i loved the show before but
your guys's advice truly changed my life
and i'm forever thankful i'm gonna cry
oh my god so she's married they're
thinking about having a family and she
got her ranch and she didn't have to
leave her mouth and it's like you can be
the rancher you don't have to marry the
rancher no and the thing is is like i'm
literally getting misty-eyed like the
thing is is like you can have it all
this girl has it all this girl is
inspiring me this is like i feel like
this is like everyone's dream and she
made it happen for herself she it's only
been months since we gave this advice
she said like a little um
maybe almost a year maybe it's a year
but like she
she believed it and she achieved it i'm
like if you can believe you can achieve
that was stunning i'm so happy for you
like you got a ranch [ __ ] yes
and you didn't have to leave your man
like when you come over yeah totally
like you need help on the farm i'll be
like lorelai from do you know any of any
hannah montana movie any adjacent
ranches for sale totally oh my god i'm
inspired i'm really happy for you that's
so great those were to your toasters and
i feel like what a great way to end the
show yeah and so if now maybe you're
feeling inspired to write in if you want
your life changed dear toasters at
gmail.com if you have an update for us
that we've already read on air you want
to update us with what's going on dear
toasters at gmail but if you just have a
query about anything relationship baby
names anything dear toasters at
gmail.com we'll always keep it anonymous
you can change people's names whatever
we'll take care of you
we will take care of you that's our show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the past life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday and youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i have radioactive box all
the places so whenever you listen to a
podcast find out this morning until
sleep the five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are if
you made it to the end of this episode
please leave a christmas tree emoji on
our
instagram because i will see the snow by
christmas like i will she will love you
guys have a great day bye